ga las tapas parte 2 el juego del año no
no lo es todo el mundo está emocionado
con el gran juego que se suponía que de
las estafas parte 2 debía ser a pesar de
las filtraciones que algunos tantos
empeñaron en negar y que ya nos dan un
presagio que tan buen juego no iba a ser
pero después de tanta especulación el
juego ya ha llegado oficialmente y que
tenemos un puntaje 95 en metacritic y un
10 de 10 en hay en la prensa lo adora
pero lo que la crítica te dice es que es
un juego hecho con mucha pasión urgió
con un arte muy bien logrado una gran
calidad de audio gran gameplay y un
juego que te transmite un gran mensaje
que en cierta parte no es tan mal lo que
la prensa no te dice es que la historia
es una completa [ __ ] se les olvidan
mencionar pequeños detalles como por
ejemplo el hecho de que yo es uno de los
personajes más humanos y más
carismáticos vistos en la última década
se ve reducido a un inútil que muere a
manos de tiger woods que la historia nos
presenta varias ideologías metidas por
sus a mente y a lo idiota sólo por el
hecho de querer ser inclusivos que el
mismo juego te obliga empatizar con un
antagonista que es francamente
insoportable y sobre todo el hecho de
que desde que comienzas la historia
hasta que terminas te das cuenta
de que no debieron haber hecho una
segunda parte cada vez es más difícil
confiar en la prensa dedicada a los
videojuegos porque te das cuenta de que
el dinero manda en ninguna crítica es el
juego hecha por algún medio medianamente
grande o conocido se atrevieron a decir
la verdad del juego y claro que no lo
iban a hacer ya sea porque hay un poco
de motivación por medio o simplemente
porque saben que no sería bueno que
hablar mal de uno de los juegos más
grandes de la generación pero sólo basta
con jugarlo para que tú mismo te des
cuenta el juego es estéticamente bello
sí y tiene un gran gameplay sí pero
todos debemos estar de acuerdo que a
pesar de que la primera parte de todas
está pues tenía un gran gameplay todo lo
que lo hizo destacar como obra y ponerlo
en un pedestal como uno de los mejores
juegos pues su maravillosa historia y la
manera de contar la cosa que en su
segunda parte ya no existe claro que
puedes argumentar que la gracia del
juego está en eso mismo jugarlo y si la
historia es mala pues al menos jugado el
en mente está bien y si tendrías razón
el hecho de que la historia sea mala no
desmerita el gran trabajo que hicieron
con su jugabilidad y su ambientación
pero como dije antes de las estafas
nunca full veo que esta cara por su gran
jugabilidad que ésta tenía por supuesto
pero era el conjunto de jugabilidad
narración grandes personajes y una
historia fantástica
se hicieron a este juego lo que es el
conclusión de los trazos parte 2 que es
un nuevo con muchas cosas destacables
que lamentablemente se ven opacadas por
decisiones estúpidas en el desarrollo
del juego es triste pensar en todo el
potencial que tenía fácilmente hubiera
podido ser el mejor juego del 2020 es un
título que personalmente no te
recomiendo para nada comprar aunque
claro es solamente un juego y si quieres
verlo por ti mismo o simplemente tienes
una opinión distinta hay que jugarlo a
pesar de todo adelante los vidente nos
vemos en la próxima